en Israël pour éviter une
hospitalisation du haut covid 19 les
statistiques montrent que le vaccin est
efficace à 85% pour les personnes âgées
et à 90% pour les jeunes jusque là rien
de surprenant pourtant sur la population
générale qui inclut les personnes âgées
et les jeunes le vaccin n'est efficace
qu'à 67% seulement que se passe-t-il
comment est-ce possible et peut-on
imaginer que dans un autre pays quand
bien même le vaccin serait efficace à
90% pour chaque catégorie d'âge de la
population il soit efficace à disons 10%
pour la population générale
à l'inverse est-ce possible que le
vaccin soit efficace à 90% pour les
jeunes mais uniquement 10% pour les
jeunes hommes et 10% pour les jeunes
femmes et si la réponse est oui à quelle
statistique faudra-t-il alors se fier
qu'est-ce qu'une bonne mesure
d'efficacité sur quelle sous population
est-il judicieux de calculer
l'efficacité
aujourd'hui on va voir que la réponse à
ces questions sont en fait loin d'être
simples et qu'elle représente un
problème plus général incroyablement
vicieux et dangereux que je vais appeler
la malédiction des généralités en gros
la malédiction des généralités c'est
quand on est obsédé par les généralités
et que c'est généralités nous conduisent
à des conclusions trompeuses
faut bien comprendre le paradoxe qu'on a
mis en avant on peut commencer par mieux
définir les chiffres de 85%, 92% et 67%.
il s'agit de l'efficacité des vaccins
vis-à-vis de l'hospitalisation dont la
définition est un peu piégeuse celle-ci
est définie comme étant un moins le
ratio de la probabilité d'être
hospitalisé sachant qu'on n'est pas
vacciné par la probabilité d'être
hospitalisé sachant qu'on est vacciné
ainsi si la vaccination est efficace la
probabilité d'être hospitalisé sachant
qu'on est vacciné devrait être beaucoup
plus petite que la probabilité d'être
hospitalisée sachant qu'on n'est pas
vacciné ou dit encore autrement leur
rapport devrait être proche de zéro la
mesure quantitative de l'efficacité sera
alors proche de 100% à l'inverse si la
vaccination n'a aucun effet alors la
probabilité d'être hospitalisée sachant
qu'on est vacciné devrait alors être à
peu près égal à la probabilité d'être
hospitalisé sachant qu'on n'est pas
vacciné auquel cas leur rapport sera
égal à 1 la mesure quantitative de
l'efficacité sera alors proche 0 ok
maintenant en pratique pour estimer
l'efficacité les probabilités sont
souvent remplacées par les fréquences
dans la population plus précisément en
utilisant la définition des probabilités
conditionnelles on remplace d'abord la
probabilité conditionnelle d'être
hospitalisée sachant qu'on est vacciné
par le ratio des probabilités
probabilités d'être hospitalisés et
vaccinée divisé par la probabilité
d'être vacciné puis on peut remplacer
chaque probabilité par leur fréquence
dans la population totale considérée
vous n'obtiens alors la probabilité
d'être hospitalisé sachant qu'on est
vacciné à peu près égal au nombre
d'hospitalisés et vaccinés divisés par N
le tout divisé par le nombre de vaccinés
divisé par N ou N et la population
totale en simplifiant on voit que la
probabilité d'être hospitalisée sachant
qu'on est vacciné est à peu près égale
au nombre d'hospitalisés et vaccinés
divisés par le nombre de vaccinés de
même on estime la probabilité d'être
hospitalisé sachant qu'on n'est pas
vacciné par le nombre de personnes qui
sont hospitalisées et non vaccinés
divisé par le nombre de non vaccinés et
donc dans le cas d'Israël si on ce ratio
disons pour les habitants hospitalisés
au cours du mois dernier on trouve alors
67% et ça c'est bien sûr très étrange
puisque c'est beaucoup moins que ceux
qui étaient annoncés il y a 8 mois et
pour tout vous dire quand j'ai vu ce
chiffre je ne me suis pas posé plus de
questions que cela je me suis dit ah
merde les vaccins sont moins efficaces
contre le variant Delta
le lait du passé était tombé à pieds
joint dans le paradoxe de Simpson dont
on va parler dans la suite et cette
idiot ne s'en était même pas rendu
compte bon à cette décharge c'est parce
que le lait du passé a rapidement
survolé un Fred qui réagissait à la
statistique 6 hospitalisés sur 10 sont
vaccinés qui est une statistique
trompeuse dont on a parlé dans l'épisode
précédent non pas à cause du paradoxe de
Simpson mais parce qu'elle ne tient pas
compte des préjugés et en particulier du
taux de base des vaccinés bref tout ça
pour dire que quand on met deux mes
informations bouddha-bou le lait du
passé peut-on des bunker une dans sa
tête et croire qu'il a fait 100% du
travail ce qui le rend très vulnérable à
la seconde
ok mais le truc vraiment bizarre en tout
de suite j'ai envie de parler
aujourd'hui dans le cas des statistiques
d'Israël c'est que alors que
l'efficacité générale du vaccin
vis-à-vis de l'hospitalisation est de
67% son efficacité pour les moins de 50
ans et de 92 % et son efficacité pour
les plus de 50 ans est de 85 %. comment
est-ce possible que les statistiques par
tranche d'âge soient aussi grandes alors
que la statistique générale est aussi
faible si vous êtes troublé par ces
observation je vous renvoie à
l'excellente vidéo de David sur le sujet
ou à celle que j'ai faite avec un
exemple de football de façon cruciale le
paradoxe de Simpson montre à quel point
les généralités sont trompeuses et pas
juste parce qu'elles sont incorrectes de
façon extrêmement contre-intuitive même
quand elles sont parfaitement factuelles
et même quand elle s'appuie sur des
chiffres tout à fait juste et sur des
calculs sans aucune erreur les
généralités peuvent aisément nous
induire en erreur elles peuvent nous
faire croire que rabiot est meilleur que
Kanté ou de manière plus critique que
l'efficacité des vaccins contre le
variant Delta vis-à-vis de
l'hospitalisation pour vous n'est que de
67%
tel est ce que j'appelle la malédiction
des généralités c'est le fait de croire
que lorsqu'elles sont factuelles les
statistiques générales nous fournissent
nécessairement des informations fiables
et non trompeuses mais ce n'est pas le
cas dès lors que celle-ci sont sujettes
à des facteurs de confusion comme l'âge
des patients c'est-à-dire des variables
qui influencent à la fois les
populations comparées et leur sort il
faut absolument se méfier de ces
statistiques générales le paradoxe de
Simpson est certainement l'un des
théorèmes mathématiques les plus
terrifiants à comprendre surtout dans le
contexte de la crise épistémique
actuelle si vous vous contentez de
généralités factuelle pour conclure vous
êtes garanti de commettre un nombre
incalculable d’erreur surtout sur des
sujets où le parti pris nous conduit à
énormément de raisonnement motivés
malheureusement à l'heure actuelle ni le
grand public ni les journalistes ni même
les scientifiques ne me semble avoir la
mesure de la malédiction de la
Généralité ainsi en science la
quasi-totalité des articles sont encore
obsédés par la quête de différence
générale par exemple sur l'efficacité
d'un traitement ou des différences entre
des sous populations typiquement hommes
femmes avec bien trop peu de
considérations pour les risques de mes
informations dues à la malédiction des
généralités et clairement la traduction
fréquentiste à coup de pévaluer net
vraiment pas dès lors il n'est pas
étonnant de constater une prolifération
de mes informations dangereuses guidées
par des généralités parfaitement
factuelles
alors je suis sûr que vous voulez mieux
comprendre le cas des vaccins comment
est-ce possible que en général leur
efficacité puisse être de 67%. alors
qu'elle est de plus de 85% pour les
jeunes et pour les moins jeunes pour
vraiment comprendre l'intuition derrière
le paradoxe de Simpson imaginons le cas
extrême où toutes les personnes âgées
sont vaccinées et toutes les personnes
jeunes ne sont pas vaccinées à ce
moment-là les vacciner sont exactement
les personnes âgées et les non vaccinés
sont exactement les jeunes mais alors
quand on compare l'hospitalisation des
vaccinés à celle des non vaccinées on
compare surtout l'hospitalisation des
vieux vaccinés à celles des jeunes non
vaccinés or comme les vieux sont
beaucoup plus à risque de base même une
fois vaccinées il demeure
potentiellement encore autant à risque
que les jeunes non vaccinés si tel est
le cas la statistique d'efficacité
générale conclura que les vaccins ne
sont pas efficaces bien sûr dans le cas
d'Israël on ne connaît pas tout à fait
là puisqu'il y a tout de même 73% de
vaccination parmi les moins de 50 ans ce
n'est pas si loin des 90% pour les plus
50 ans néanmoins cette différence suffit
à faire en sorte que les vacciner soient
aussi plus probablement vieux et donc
quand même pas mal à risque à cause de
leur âge par opposition à des noms
vaccinés qui sont plus probablement plus
jeunes et donc partiellement protégé par
leur âge ceci dit est de façon très
préoccupante notre raisonnement montre
que dans un autre pays avec des
circonstances différentes pourvu que les
vieux vaccinés demeurent davantage à
risque que les jeunes non vaccinés il
est tout à fait concevable que la
statistique générale suggère désormais
la tangiosité des vaccins autrement dit
dans un tel pays surtout si les jeunes
ne se vaccinent pas on peut très bien
avoir une efficacité générale des
vaccins qui deviennent négatives les
statistiques générales suggéreraient
alors à tort que les vaccins sont
néfastes et qu'on y perd à ce vacciner
et ça en fait petit très banking ça
risque en fait d'arriver dans les pays
déjà beaucoup infectés si ces personnes
déjà infectées ne sont pas encouragés à
se faire vacciner j' un peu plus encore
sur cette possibilité terrifiante en
effet on pourrait en arriver à comparer
des déjà infectés non vaccinés à des non
infectés vaccinés or les infectés non
vaccinées semblent plus protégés que les
non infectés vaccinés autre explication
importante le Pass sanitaire celui-ci
encourage les non infectés à ce vacciner
beaucoup plus qu'il n'encourage les
infectés à ce vacciner ainsi la
comparaison entre vacciner et non
vacciné risque d'être dans les mois à
venir de plus en plus une comparaison
entre des non infectées vaccinées et des
infectées non vaccinés mais ce n'est pas
tout qui plus est grâce au Pass
sanitaire les vaccinés devraient
beaucoup plus aller au restaurant ou au
cinéma ce qui augmente leur exposition
au covid si cette exposition est 10 fois
supérieure ce seul phénomène de
surexposition des vaccinés suffirait en
fait à faire en sorte que la probabilité
qu'un vaccinet doit aller à l'hôpital
soit aussi grande que la probabilité
qu'un non-vexiné y aille bref en
combinant toutes ces raisons pour les
appelle les vacciner forme a priori une
population plus vulnérable et exposée il
semble en fait probable que dans les
mois à venir au moins quelque part en
France la population des vaccinés soit
plus à risque de se retrouver à
l'hôpital que la population des
non-vaccinés quand bien même pour chacun
individu tout exposition au virus = par
ailleurs le vaccin demeure efficace à
90%
tel est l'ampleur de la malédiction de
la Généralité parce que le jour où ça ça
arrive vous pouvez être sûr que les
rayons de la Fnac seront remplis de
propos très dangereusement trompeurs
mais parfaitement justifié par des
généralités entièrement factuelles mais
soumis à cette horrible paradoxe de
Simpson
alors vous qui connaissez maintenant le
paradoxe de Simpson vous vous dites
peut-être que vous pourrez maintenant
aller sur Twitter et prendre de haut
tout ce qui tombe dans le piège de ce
paradoxe mais avant de faire cela
posez-vous la question dans le cas des
statistiques d'Israël en a-t-on vraiment
fini avec ce paradoxe est-ce que en
partageant les statistiques par tranche
d'âge on a vraiment résolu la
malédiction des généralités après tout
les statistiques pour les moins de 50
ans en Israël même si c'est moins
général que de parler de la population
générale en Israël ça reste une
statistique générale non mais du coup le
chiffre de 92% pour les moins de 50 ans
ne pourrait-il pas lui-même être sujet
au paradoxe de Simpson est-ce possible
par exemple que si on redécoupe cette
population des moins de 50 ans par genre
par origin ethnique ou par localisation
géographique ou par niveau
socio-économique ou par antécédent
médicaux notamment vis-à-vis des
infections antérieures au covid-19
est-ce possible qu'en regardant
davantage de facteurs de confusion
se retrouve alors des efficacités du
vaccin toutes égales à disons 10% à quel
moment peut-on conclure qu'une
statistique générale n'est plus soumise
à la malédiction des généralités alors
je vais vous ne pas savoir exactement ce
que répondrait un statisticien
fréquentiste à ces questions les en
croire ceux que j'ai cité notamment dans
l'épisode 13 certains fréquentistes
proposeraient peut-être de se fier à la
connaissance d'un expert c'est en tout
cas ce que suggère David loi prend dans
son excellente vidéo sur le paradoxe de
Simpson citer les le cas j'ai envie de
dire qu'il s'agit là avant tout d'une
résolution partiellement bayésienne de
la malédiction des généralités car elle
fait finalement appel aux préjugés de
l'expert c'est-à-dire d'un jugement
préalable qui s'appuie sur des
informations complètement absentes des
statistiques qui lui sont présentées
quoi qu'il en soit si on adopte
pleinement la casquette byzienne il est
clair que ces préjugés sont absolument
critiques pour éviter la malédiction des
généralités en particulier imaginons que
la seule chose que vous sachiez c'est
que l'efficacité générale des vaccins en
Israël est égal à 67 que feriez-vous de
cette donnée clairement à cause du
paradoxe Simpson vous ne pourrez pas
l'utiliser pour conclure que
l'efficacité pour un individu donné sera
de 67%. mais est-ce pour autant qu'il
faut ignorer cette donnée dès lors
qu'elle est soumise un risque de
paradoxe de Simpson la généralité
doit-elle être complètement
ignorée et si oui peut-on alors
considérer que toute statistique est une
généralité et ignorer ainsi toutes les
statistiques pour le vaien en tout cas
la réponse est non toute statistique est
une donnée et toute donnée doit être
exploité pour mettre à jour nos
crédences cependant cette mise à jour
doit obéir rigoureusement aux lois des
probabilités ce qui dans le cas des
données observationnelles peut-être
piéger en fait pour bien effectuer cela
pour le baysien il faut absolument
interpréter cette donnée dans le cadre
de différentes théories qui nous
semblent crédibles et si étant donné
typiquement des estimations des taux de
vaccination chez les jeunes et les moins
jeunes et sachant la vulnérabilité est
plus grande des moins jeunes nous semble
alors probable d'obtenir une efficacité
générale de 60% alors le chiffre de 67%
devra alors nous faire légèrement
augmenter nos crédences en efficacité du
vaccin en s'appuyant sur le byzanisme et
en particulier sur les préjugés on peut
également justifier l'existence de
certaines statistiques moins sujettes à
la malédiction des généralités et donc
probablement plus désirable à
communiquer en pratique typiquement si
nous paraît très crédible que l'âge est
un facteur de confusion qui si les prix
en compte changent complètement les
mesures d'efficacité il paraîtra alors
désirable de calculer les statistiques
par tranche d'âge à l'inverse en
pratique on peut considérer qu'une
statistique générale est suffisamment
non tropeuse s'il paraît peu crédible à
ceux qui s'y connaissent le mieux
qu'elles puissent être subdivisée en
statistique plus spécifiques
radicalement distincte mais s'il y a
avant tout une chose à retenir de
l'analyse Bayern du paradoxe de Simpson
peut-être plus encore que le rôle
central des préjugés pour le décortiquer
c'est le fait que en pratique les
probabilités qui comptent vraiment ce ne
sont pas les statistiques générales dans
ma balance risque bénéfices pour décider
de me vacciner il ne me faut en fait pas
regarder à des statistiques comme la
probabilité d'être hospitalisé sachant
qu'on est vacciné ou qu'on n'est pas
vacciné non dans mon cas personnel les
probabilités qui comptent ce sont les
probabilités d'être hospitalisés sachant
qu'on est vacciné et qu'on est
l'individulé par opposition à la
probabilité d'être hospitalisée sachant
qu'on n'est pas vacciné et qu'on ait
l'individulé ou dans le fait de
conditionner par les on tient en compte
de mon âge mon genre mon originalité ma
localisation géographique mon niveau
socio-économique et en fait même avant
tout mise antécédents médicaux et ça
c'est critique à comprendre car en
probabilité on sait très bien que la
probabilité conditionnelle probabilité
d'être hospitalisée sachant qu'on est
vacciné et qu'on est laid est en général
très différente de la probabilité d'être
hospitalisée sachant qu'on est vacciné
les informations additionnelles peuvent
complètement bouleverser nos estimations
de la probabilité d'un événement donné
malheureusement de nos jours dans les
médias sur les réseaux sociaux et dans
la recherche scientifique les
généralités restent ceux qui prédominent
et on oublie trop souvent de
conditionner adéquattements nos
estimations probabilistes à titre
d'exemple une publication récente dans
Science ouvre par la conclusion que la
protection par une infection antérieure
et plus grande que celle par la
vaccination autrement dit le résultat
phare de cette publication en tout cas
celle qui avait largement en avant c'est
une comparaison entre la probabilité
d'être hospitalisé sachant qu'on a été
infecté précédemment et la probabilité
précédemment vacciné cependant a bien y
réfléchir ces quantités ont très peu
d'intérêts pratiques notamment pour la
vaccination à titre individuel ce qui
importe c'est davantage la probabilité
d'être hospitalisé sachant qu'on a été
précédemment infecté et qu'on est
vacciné par opposition à la probabilité
d'être hospitalisée sachant qu'on a été
précédemment infecté et qu'on est
toujours pas vacciné en tout cas dans le
cas des individus infectés et pour la
personne qui ne sont pas infectées ce
qui importe c'est de comparer la
probabilité d'être hospitalisé sachant
qu'on n'a pas précédemment affecté par
le covid-19 et qu'on est vacciné par
opposition à la probabilité d'être
hospitalisé sachant qu'on n'a pas été
précédemment infecté et qu'on n'est pas
vacciné ce n'est malheureusement que
dans un second temps que ces
statistiques plus importantes sont
citées dans la publication et f-wi elle
suggère fortement qu'on y gagne à être
vacciné qu'on ait été infecté
préalablement ou non malheureusement
même les scientifiques n'ont pas
développé d'immunité robuste face à la
terrible malédiction des généralités et
face à l'importance de conditionner
adéquatement les probabilités qu'on
évalue et qu'on communique il est gros
temps que ensemble on cherche tous à
faire mieux